foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar unlocking
the power of aav and lvv analytics
insights and strategies for optimizing
viral Vector Purity analysis I am
Shelley mulak of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar has been
organized by biotechnic using the lab
Roots platform to earn more to learn
more about biotechnic products and
services please visit their website at
bio-technic.com
as a reminder today's webinar is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education icon
on the far left of your screen to obtain
your credits we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
also if you experience any technical
questions you can utilize the QA box and
we will assist you directly
I'd like to now cordially welcome
today's speaker Dr Chris Hager director
of application science analytical
Solutions division of biotechnic Welcome
Dr higger the floor is yours
thank you for the introduction it's a
pleasure to be back with you today at
lab roots to talk about unlocking the
power of aav and lvv Analytics
today we will talk about insights and
strategies for optimizing viral Vector
Purity analysis on our Marie's platform
viruses have a natural ability to
deliver genetic material into cells and
therefore some gene therapy products are
derived from viruses
once viruses have been modified to
remove the ability to cause infectious
disease these modified viruses can be
used as vectors or vehicles to carry
therapeutic genes into human cells
the majority of current cell in gene
therapies leverage three key viral
vectors for direct gene therapy via in
Vivo delivery aavs and adenovirus are
being directly administered to the
patient
the other major therapy which happens ex
Vivo or also known as Cell Therapy
requires extracting cells from the
patient and modifying these cells by
either viral or non-viral approaches
as shown in the schematic lentivirus is
the main viral Vector used for
transforming cells in ex-vivo cell
therapy
after the cells have been programmed
they are reintroduced into the patient
where the cells can now Target a tumor
importantly all three viruses need to be
produced in high amounts with
consistency and quality
there are battery of tests to monitor
these parameters and what's typically
referred to as viral Vector Analytics
there are several challenges associated
with analyzing viral vectors
first viruses are complex and require
extensive characterization unlike
monoclonal antibodies viruses contain
both a protein as well as a genetic
component
and unlike monocol antibodies viruses
share Less in common with each other
requiring independent methods to be
developed for each virus
many analytical platforms serve a single
purpose requiring significant capital
and infrastructure Investments to test
for all cqas across various products
most analytical platforms require large
sample volumes of pure or near pure
material
this makes method development for
analytical platforms challenging
and lastly some analytical platforms
require years of experience to operate
making these platforms challenging to
implement in QC
Maurice is the next Generation capillary
electrophoresis platform to support
biovector analytics and address these
challenges
Maurice has two separation modes cescs
which separates proteins by size can be
used for viral Vector identity and
Purity analysis of viral vectors
Maurice also has the gold standard image
CIF which is ideal for charged
heterogeneity analysis of
Biotherapeutics and specifically for
capsic content and stability analysis of
viral vectors
the platform is capable of providing
answers in as few as five and a half
minutes allowing for both fast answers
as well as rapid method development
our compass for ice software is 21 part
11 CFR compliant and features an
optional and power control capability
for those already operating in the
Empower ecosystem
and lastly something many QC departments
absolutely love about Maurice is the
ease of use
the instrument is Plug and Play plug in
your cartridge consumables and samples
and get running almost as fast as you
can eat your lunch
the cartridges dictate the Run mode we
have a CIF cartridge the brand new flex
cartridge for CIF fractionation
the cesds plus cartridge and the Turbo
csds cartridge
today we will be focusing on data from
the CES plus and turbo cesds cartridges
for viral Vector analysis
in addition to being easy to use as I
mentioned before the Morris platform
solves the other key challenges by
supporting several viral vectors cqas on
a single capillary electrophoresis
platform with a small footprint and
modest capital investment
Maurice cesds can support viral Vector
identity potency and purity
additionally with our CIF mode capsued
content analysis can be enabled and can
help with particle stability
characterization as well
viral Vector Purity is an important
critical quality attribute that needs to
be assessed as we were just discussing
the ich q6b states that in addition to
evaluating the purity of the drug
substance and Drug product the
manufacturer should also assess
impurities which may be present
they can be of known structure partially
characterized or unidentified
talking about these impurities Dark
Horse Consulting releases a white paper
a few months ago that nicely summarizes
types of impurities found in viral
vectors
the first called process related
impurities include things like host cell
DNA and hostile protein media components
Downstream processing reagents like
endonucleases
and AV capsided protein Stoichiometry
can also be classified here
the other type of impurities known as
product related impurities include
degraded viral vectors empty particles
as well as aggregated viral particles
we have developed a robust cescs method
to look at the viral Vector Purity
across aav led to virus and adenovirus
let's now take a look at the method
let's walk through our viral Vector
Purity method for Maurice cesds
because viral vectors are typically
formulated with salts to improve
stability
and these salts can influence cscs
electrokinetic injection
we developed an approach that easily
removes excipients and can permit sample
concentration
first we take an aav virus sample and
add four times the volume of ice cold
acetone to precipitate the virus
we like to put these samples at minus 20
degrees C for an hour but even
immediately after acetone precipitation
does work
to pallet the precipitate next
centrifuge the sample at 15 000 times G
for 10 minutes and then decant the
supernatant letting the pellet dry for 5
minutes before proceeding to the next
step
which is
reconstitution and denaturation
below is a table showing the various
reconstitution and denaturing conditions
for aav
lentivirus and adenovirus
you'll note that lentivirus has a
different reconstitution buffer compared
to adenovirus and aav
and lensivirus also has different
denaturation conditions
we reduce the samples across all three
viruses
and I've importantly included here our
pre and activation step
because both lentivirus and adenovirus
are considered bsl2
we pre-inactivate these before working
with them as described in the table
after the samples have been denatured
we cool them on ice and centrifuge
then we add three to six full volume of
water which is for water stacking mix
that significantly dilutes out any
remaining sample components
it's important here to not reheat the
sample
and then analyze on Maurice
the acetone precipitation method I just
described can increase signal 6-fold
without the adjustment of sample volume
Sean this slide is an av-9 sample for
cscs analysis
we either directly analyze a 20
microliter av-9 sample shown in blue or
processed 20 microliters through the
workflow I just described and
reconstituted in 20 microliters of csds
plus buffer shown in Orange
there's a 6X increase in Signal across
the three capsid proteins
now if you're only looking at AV capsule
ratio as shown by the table here
you don't need to precipitate your
sample and can get your answer directly
however if you're looking for impurities
as shown in this inset the precipitation
approach affords better detection of
lower molecular impurities as well as
the aav genome
while there are varied methods to
prepare the viral vectors as discussed
on the previous Slide the good news is
that the Maurice csds methods are
platform
in fact we use the default more ecscs
methods for all of our viral Vector
analysis
shown here are both the turbo cescs and
cescs plus cartridge conditions and run
conditions that we use
including both the injection times and
voltages and the separation times and
voltages
now that we have our viral Vector prep
work in hand as well as the Maurice
methods let's start taking a look at the
individual viruses and some Maurice data
to help support cqa analysis
the deno-associated viruses or aavs are
mainly used in in Vivo gene therapy
AVS are small viruses at around 25
nanometers and contain a single stranded
DNA Genome of approximately 4.7
kilobases
from a protein perspective there are
three capsid co-proteins vp1 vp2 and vp3
that form a 60 MERP capsid
tropism is dictated by different
serotypes for example av1 versus 2
versus 3 and so on
AVS are mostly non-integrating
and have low immunogenicity making them
quite attractive gene therapy delivery
vehicles
and lastly an important number here the
number of clinical trials is over 250
just demonstrating the vast importance
and utility of these viruses for gene
therapy
let's now take a look at some data
the three aav capsid proteins vp1 vp2
and vp3 assign them to a 60 Mr capsid at
a theoretical ratio of 1 to 1 to 10.
experimentally this ratio also called
capsid proteins Stoichiometry varies
widely based on serotype production
system and even production batch
whatever the reason Maurice can
accurately measure the ratio of these
proteins
show on the left are five av-9 vectors
with different cargos all produced in
sf9 insect cells
the three viral proteins vp3 vp2 and vp1
are clearly resolved from each other
allowing for highly accurate
quantification
the capsis stoichiometries are shown in
the table and ranged from 16 to 1 to 1
up to nearly 27 to 1 to 1 for vp3 to 2
to 1.
these ratios increase with the size of
the cargo suggesting that more vp3 is
needed to encapsulate The genome
we also looked at different serotypes as
shown on the right
this time we evaluated a V1 av6 and aav9
all with the same cargo
the capsid psychiometries are much
closer in these samples at approximately
14 to 1 to 1.
in addition the method can be used as an
identity assay as only aav1 and aav6
have the small vp3 truncation running
right below the vp3 peak
the cescs method also produces highly
consistent aav capsid proteins
stoichiometries
here we are looking at data generated on
a CS turbo cartridge where we prepared
10 independent av-9 preparations and
injected for a total of 93 times
shown in the middle is a turbo cscs run
summary looking at three aav
preparations and 18 injections per day
for three days
and on the right is our cscs plus result
for 45 injections from the single well
of the av-9 all these samples were
analyzed at 4 times 10 to the 11th viral
particles per well
in the table on the bottom left There's
a summary of the average capsid ratios
or stoichiometries obtained from either
the turbo cartridge for one day three
days or the CES plus cartridge result
as can be seen the capsule ratio across
all three of these examples is quite
consistent at approximately 15 to 0.8 to
1.
shown in the table on the bottom right
is the Precision of the percent Peak
area across the three tests and the
three viral proteins
showing that the results are highly
consistent both within a run and
day-to-day across two different cscs
cartridges
after testing the method reproducibility
we tested the linearity of the method to
do this we took various starting volumes
of 1 times 10 to the 13th VP per ml
sample of av-9 from 40 microliters down
to one microliter and process them
through the workflow I described earlier
before analysis on Maurice
this sample range equates to a test
between 10 to the 13th and 10 to the
11th viral particles per mil
we were able to detect signal using as
little as 5 microliters of the stock
material and observed excellent
linearity across the test range as shown
on the right
because Maurice is ideally suited for
late stage products this detection range
is nicely aligned with AV concentrations
available at these stages of production
you may notice that there are a number
of lower molecular weight impurities
that can be seen in these data
let's take a closer look at impurity
analysis using a few different av-9
samples
as I mentioned earlier the precipitation
method affords better detection of
impurities
taking the five av-9 samples with
different cargo we were looking at
earlier and zooming in a bit closer to
these samples we can see that they
aren't 100 pure
in fact by looking at the inset table
which measures the total purity of these
samples
two of them don't even break ninety
percent pure
the Maurice cscs method can measure low
levels impurities as shown across the
various samples
because we are using direct detection
with Maurice identifying these
impurities isn't possible
however I remind you that biotechnie
offers ultra-sensitive assays for both
hek293t detection as well as Nokia or
benzonase residuals on our simpleplex
platform
let's now switch gears and take a look
at lentivirus
moving on to lentiviral vectors or lvvs
their main use is for xvivo Gene
modified cell therapy
lvv particles are significantly larger
than aavs measuring between 80 and 100
nanometers
unlike aavs lvvs have a single stranded
RNA genome and it's about double the
size of the aav genome
when tiviral vectors are significantly
more complex than aavs being an envelope
virus and contain at least 18 proteins
a major protein p24 forms the capsic
coat and is used for viral titer
lvvs also contain 35 lipid and three
percent carbohydrate adding to their
analytical complexity
lvv is pseudotype for delivery most
commonly with bsvg but also with other
surface glycoproteins like the Ebola
glycoprotein
lvv integrates into the genome which is
one of the reasons it works well for
cell therapy applications
lvv immunogenicity is moderate to high
so care must be taken when removing free
virus from Cell Therapy preparations
and lastly there are over 300 clinical
trials currently in Flight that leverage
lvv demonstrating its importance in the
field
let's now take a look at some more easy
SDS data
as I just mentioned lvv is a complex
virus with more than 18 proteins
consistently characterized
in fact we were able to detect 23 unique
protein peaks in an lvv sample from
Takara with the cesds method
it's quite a different profile from aav
here but allowed me to provide a little
insight into the identity of some of
these Peaks
the second Peak from the left is p24
which we have verified by both
recombinant protein spikins as I'll show
you in a minute as well as by our simple
Western platform
and by a parent molecular weight we can
likely label Peak 9 as vsvg and Peak 15
is gp120
two other notes I'd like to make here
first Peak 8 in this image could easily
be divided into three Peaks for an even
more granular measurement of the profile
and second we know the sample contains
around 10 micrograms per mL of hek293
host cell protein which may contribute
to the additional Peaks we observe
on the right I've performed the lvv
capsid protein Stoichiometry measurement
this time using p24 as the fixed protein
at one
because p24 is the major capsid protein
inside of lvv ensuring consistency in
its levels relative to other proteins is
critical
despite the highly complex profile the
method is highly reproducible
let's first take a look at the
reproducibility of a single lvv sample
show on the left are 45 injections from
the same 20 microliter lvv sample with
near perfect overlay
for analysis here I took the total area
under the curves from RMC 1.1 to 2.2
the percent RSD for these 45 injections
was only 2.91 percent giving high
confidence that within a run you'll get
the same data across the entire batch
let's see how the method held up to
testing over multiple days
for this test we precipitated a new lvv
sample each day and performed 18
injections per day for three days for a
total of 54 injections
again we observed a very reproducible
profile with a three-day percent rst of
only 3.38 percent for the total area
demonstrating the Maurice cescs provides
excellent reproducibility both within
and between batches or days
lastly we more recently tested a new
batch of lvv with our turbo CES
cartridge shown on the right
again we achieved excellent
reproducibility at only 1.92 rst across
nine injections and three sample
preparations
now for those of you with a careful eye
you will notice that the profile of the
lvv from the turbo cartridge is
different
and that's correct and it's a completely
different batch of lvv although from the
same manufacturer Takara
this underscores how Maurice can monitor
batch to match consistency of your viral
Vector products
we next explored the lvv cescs method
linearity
an lvv sample was serial diluted and
analyzed on Maurice to establish
methylenearity as well as limited
detection
on the left is a dilution series of lvv
from 7 times 10 to the ninth Tu per ml
down to 2.3 times 10 to the eighth Tu
per ml compared to a blank shown in dark
blue
nearly all lvv proteins are detectable
across the entire dilution range
a plot of this solution series was used
to determine the LOD as well as the loq
as shown on the right where an r squared
of 0.98 was obtained
the LOD was calculated by dividing three
times the standard deviation of the
response by the slope of the calibration
curve and the loq was calculated using
10 times the standard deviation of the
response divided by the slope
the LOD and loq values are both close to
4 times to the seventh Tu per ml
so take it together the lvvc SCS method
is highly reproducible as well as
responsive over a wide dilution range
quantitating the amount of p24 is one of
the main methods for determining lvv
viral titer which is used to ensure
proper lvv dosing for Gene delivery
in this experiment lvv samples were
spiked with varying concentrations of
p24 and analyzed using the Mori cesds
method
on the left is the set of
electropherograms of either lvv alone
shown in the light blue or with
increasing amounts of the recombinant
p24 available from biotechnie spiked in
the results of the p24 spiked in lvv
titration help identify the p24 peak
within this complex profile
the peak area values from this
experiment were plotted against the p24
concentration to generate a titration
curve shown on the right
comparing to the relationship of one
nanogram of p24 for every 10 to the
fifth Tu as established in the nature
publication
the tighter concentration from this
study was estimated to be approximately
8.5 micrograms per mL of p24 and an lvv
10 to the ninth Tu per ml sample which
is within 15 percent of the theoretical
value
as Salon gene therapy manufacturers
increase the number of programs that are
being run concurrently the need for
identity assays becomes even more
critical as similar products are often
produced
we've had the opportunity to compare two
lentivaro vendors and have shown that
our cscs assay is an identity assay
which would be similar to monitoring
different programs
shown on the slide are two vendors of
lvv with the same genetic insert analyze
at the same concentration
the profiles are both complex as
expected the vendor 2 has fewer Peaks
than vendor one and I've called out some
of the main differences with the blue
arrows
we've now completed both our aav and
Lindsay viral work and have recently
started working on adenovirus
let's now take a look at our last viral
Vector for today's talk
moving on to our last viral Vector of
today adenovirus is experiencing a
re-emergence for in Vivo gene therapy
adenoviral particles are similar in size
to lentivars
but have significantly larger and
double-stranded DNA genome at 36
kilobases
from a protein perspective this virus
has at least 13 unique proteins that can
be divided into major and minor
components where the major proteins
account for more than 60 percent of the
content
based on mass spec data there are over 1
000 proteins within a single adenoviral
particle
like aavs
denovirus comes with different serotypes
that dictate tissue tropism
and unlike the other viruses covered
today adenovirus does not integrate into
the genome
high immunogenicity is experienced with
adenovirus since it is thought that
everyone hasn't been infected with at
least one adenovirus in their life
I know I have and it's like a cold on
steroids
now there are of course mitigation
strategies for this immunogenicity which
is clear by the number of clinical
trials currently using adenovirus a
number that is more than lovv and aav
combined
let's now take a look at some adenovirus
data on Maurice
using the method described earlier in
the talk we analyze some adenovirus type
5 CMV gfp by Maurice csds
shown on the left are triplicate
injections of the 10 to the 12 VP per ml
sample
I've annotated several Peaks that we've
either confirmed by an orthogonal
technique as was the case for the purple
colored hexon protein or by molecular
weight inference for the others
additionally we notice that above the
hexon protein there were many
irreproducible spikes
after nucleus a digestion which is shown
on the right we were able to confirm
that these Peaks correspond to the ad5
genome
you can also appreciate the generation
of several low moleculared species upon
genome digestion shaded in Gray in the
electroferograms on the right
similar to aav and lvv we looked at
method reproducibility and we're pleased
to see excellent repeat injection data
with a hexon protein RSD below one
percent and all rfcs under 11 percent
from these data we were able to estimate
the major and minor protein groups as
well as individual levels
from our data the major proteins
accounted for nearly 75 percent of the
signal slightly higher than expected and
the minor proteins accounted for 17
percent of the signal
with the remaining eight percent for the
low molecular weight species generated
by the DNA genome digestion
on the right is a capsid protein ratio
analysis where I set the fiber protein
to one and everything else is reported
as a full difference from the fiber
protein
I did this to show an example of a test
measurement that could be made routinely
for batch to batch consistency testing
for adenovirus
lastly we tested the adenovirus cesds
method linearity
using the same adenovirus 5 stock at
three times ten of the 12 VP per ml we
independently precipitated 50 40 30 2010
or 5 microliters of virus and processed
as described earlier
this test range equates to 3 times 10 to
the 12 feet P per ml down to 3 times 10
to the 11th VP per ml
on the right is the linearity based on
the average Peak area of the hexon
protein in the top five samples as the 5
microliter sample was at the noise of
the method
therefore we can detect as little as 1.6
times 10 to the ninth total viral
particles per well
or around 6 times 10 to the 11th VP per
ml which is about 10 microliters of
stock
it's time to wrap up our time together
today
viral vectors are complex Therapeutics
with a wide variety of critical quality
attributes that need to be routinely
tested
today we discussed a series of robust
Maurice cesds methods that can be
applied to multiple viral vectors
including aavs lvvs and adenovirus
I demonstrated excellent comparability
between our turbo csds and cescs plus
cartridges
showing that you have excellent coverage
across your entire development pipeline
whether you need Ultra fast answers with
many samples or high Precision sample
analysis with fewer samples in QC
and taken together Maurice is a single
analytical platform that is ideal for
late stage viral Vector characterization
and with that I'd like to thank you for
your attention and time today and would
be happy to answer any questions
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for let's
get started so our first question is uh
can Maurice icief be used for aav
characterization
yeah I hope you can hear me okay Shelly
um yeah it's a great question of course
today we focused on cesds analysis with
the Maurice platform but certainly there
have been a number of great examples of
using our image CIF mode for a the
analysis including both denatured capsid
analysis as well as intact particle
analysis
oh great thank you for that okay
um our next question is how quickly were
these CE SDS methods developed
yeah so today we talked about three
right the aav the lentium the adenovirus
they all share kind of a common workflow
right the precipitation and the reprap
and and then the running I would say
that you know we started with aav and
admittedly that took us maybe a couple
weeks to really understand and really
develop the core method the
precipitation approach and so forth but
when when we started to apply that to
lentivirus as well as adenovirus those
were nearly TurnKey especially the
adenovirus where we didn't really change
anything about the prep compared to aav
with lenti because it was a little bit
more difficult to break open we we
certainly had to make some changes to
the denaturation protocol as well as the
Recon buffer but overall you know the AV
and sorry the adenovirus and lenty
methods were both within two to three
days
wow okay
um great our next question is how uh
let's see I noticed that the capsid
ratios you showed were rarely 10 one to
one in the ratio can you comment on the
difference from expected
yes that ten to one to one is is kind of
a a mixed blessing it's it's a
theoretical number right so it you
should get theoretically 10 VP threes
for every one of ep2 and every one of
vp1 but experimentally that's rarely the
case there have been capsule ratios
reported uh include you know hundreds of
individual protein and it's a stochastic
measurement so it is subject to change
and really each sample that you have
contains not a single capture ratio but
a variety of capsid ratios you can even
have vp3 only capsids for example so
it's not it's not going to ever be ten
to one to one exactly I think more
importantly if you get a reproducible
capsid ratio that you can measure
consistently across process steps or
batches I think that's what's really
critical
yeah that makes sense thank you yeah
um and then the next one that we have
coming in the next question we have is
uh for adenovirus work if the nucleus
digestion causes the lmws is it worth
doing prior to analysis
yes that's a great a good question I
guess that'd be a little bit of personal
preference so it's absolutely you know
the right questions the nuclease cuts
all that high molecular weight dma
species from The genome but uh in doing
so it makes those low molecular species
which can mask some of the very small
adenine viral proteins
um so it really would depend on whether
you are okay seeing those kind of
variable DNA spikes or if you really
need that that clean consistent profile
so it'd really be a user's choice
okay excellent uh the next question is
lots of questions today it's great the
next question is keeping the complexity
of lvv in mind which cartridge would you
suggest for cesds analysis
yes of the three viruses we talked about
today Lindsay virus is certainly the
most complex over 23
identifiable peaks in the profile that
we found right so
um if you're looking for the best
resolution between each of those Peak
species I'd recommend the plus cartridge
that'll give you the best resolution now
the the flip side is because the
separations take 35 minutes per
injection you may want to
um in earlier Upstream samples use the
turbo cartridge which is significantly
faster at about eight minutes of sample
you may compromise your resolution
slightly but we've shown that the
quantification between the two
cartridges for lvb is quite good
that's very helpful okay
um our next question is
um what kind of positive controls should
be used on the Maurice platform
I guess I'd think about two different
types of controls the first one would be
more about system suitability and we
certainly offer for both mncif and cests
the system suitability molecules that
essentially just tell you that your
separations your instrument your
cartridge and consumables are all
working as expected all right so that's
really just to qualify make sure the
system is operating and then you know
appropriate controls for for your
program or for what you're working on
right so
um for example for capsid ratio you may
want to have a known capture ratio
standard that you can use as a reference
if you're doing a tighter measurement
you're going to want a known tighter
sample you can use for a standard curve
um
and for things like image CIF you may
want different post-translationally
modified species or different mutations
things like that so there are a lot of
controls that are probably more specific
to what you're actually doing and then
there are a few controls that we do
commercially offer to help with again
that General system suitability
excellent all right well it looks like
we have time for one more question
um so our final question today is is the
Maurice platform suitable for analysis
of natural samples and then there's a
second part to the question which is for
viruses that were Amplified in plants
oh that's a good question I don't think
we've at this time looked at any uh
viruses that have been Amplified and
plant but I don't see a reason why we
wouldn't be able to look at those the
um you know especially if it's isolated
right so the Maurice is the direct
detection system uses absorbance right
so you'll see everything in the sample
so very complex samples you'll get a
very complicated profile with so you
know a virus derived from plant itself I
wouldn't see a concern with if you're
trying to run a plant lysate that might
be something more appropriate for our
simple Western technology which is
really geared towards complex samples
like lysates
um and then the first part of that
question uh would you mind repeating
Shelly I got the second part of the
virus and plants
yeah it's it said is the Maurice
platform suitable for
both couples so yes I guess
I can tell you that we're analyzing some
pretty wild things that are natural
currently like milk
um and other you know other things that
are naturally occurring I suppose
um but that again as I said there's a
differentiation Maurice is great for
your Downstream more direct analysis and
then you may want to look into our
simple Western for those really complex
natural samples like serum plasma and so
forth
but it's fantastic well thank you again
Dr Hager for your time today and for
your important research uh do you have
any final comments for our audience
no I mean I'd like to thank everybody
for your attendance and your great
questions today certainly you know I
would recommend check our website for
more information feel free to reach out
to myself or others at the organization
if you have specific questions we're
always here to help support your
research
great wonderful thank you again Dr
hugger we'd also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor biotechnic founder
writing today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions uh questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab Roots will
alert you by email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone goodbye
bye thanks thank you